sabe por qué muchos sitios web le piden
ahora que acepte o rechace las cookies y
otras tecnologías de rastreo la
normativa europea ha cambiado y ahora la
instalación de cookies requiere su
consentimiento esto le permite disponer
de más información y un mayor control
sobre el uso de sus datos
de qué se trata en la práctica cuando
llega a france24 y antes de acceder a
los contenidos aparecerá una ventana
para registrar su decisión de aceptar o
rechazar la cookies o de configurar sus
preferencias esta decisión puede
expresarse de forma global acepto
rechazo por finalidad analítica web y
personalización y por socio reproductor
de vídeo y redes sociales qué
consecuencias tiene esta decisión cuando
hace clic en aceptar todo nos autoriza a
nosotros ya nuestros socios a tratar sus
datos para optimizar su experiencia
disfrutará de una experiencia completa
en france 24 gracias al análisis de la
calidad de su navegación
informativa podrá cambiar para adaptarse
mejor a sus necesidades al hacer clic en
rechazar todo nosotros y nuestros socios
no contaremos con la información
necesaria para ofrecerle una experiencia
óptima algunas acciones o consultas
dejarán de estar disponibles por ejemplo
no podrá leer los tweets en los
artículos y la publicidad que aparecerá
será de peor calidad
al hacer clic en configurar puede
especificar las empresas y los motivos
para los que acepta o no que se trate en
sus datos su experiencia en france24 o
sea para sus preferencias y a la
personalización que haya configurado por
ejemplo puede dar su consentimiento para
la coopi de analítica web y rechazar las
cookies de publicidad dirigida pueden
modificar sus preferencias en cualquier
momento haciendo clic en el enlace
centro de preferencias de nuestro menú
le esperamos en france 24